today we are checking out a new Mophie
charger this was just released fairly
recently but what makes this special is
unlike most other movie chargers this
one has an AC charging port so things
that you would normally plug into the
wall you can now plug in to this guy I
probably don't even need this knife to
be honest with you but what kind of
unboxing would it be if I didn't have it
USB USB C an AC devices Wow oh my
goodness this thing is massive
I am shocked jeez I don't know what I
was expecting I mean this is kind of a
heavy box oh crap this is actually
massive it's really bad thank you this
comes with two cables normally it
usually only comes with one but this
comes with actually they're both USB see
so this is USB type a and then C and
this one is just two USB sees which is
quite exciting you can never have enough
for USB C cables so here is our 30 watt
USB C this is a fast charging port
here's our USB a it's a high output
charging at 2.4 amps right here is our
LED monitor see how much battery life we
have left and it looks like we've got a
half charge which is excellent and here
we have what makes this movie so special
this is 110 volts 100 watt AC output
this looks like it's just a little fan
which I assume this thing can probably
put out a little bit of heat because it
is a massive battery
it's got like a nice fabric finish which
to be completely honest with you I'm not
a huge fan of this well I don't like the
fabric e texture of it that's my
personal preference because I don't like
this feeling but beside that I do like
it because it doesn't slip around on
surfaces like this desk does give a
little bit of grip so it doesn't move
around too much which is nice so it
looks like this button will activate
your AC plug so unless you push this
button this isn't gonna be activated
unnecessarily I'm shocked that it's
charging like it's doing its job it's
not something that I should be surprised
about but you can see here the light is
on so that signifies the AC is producing
an output and with that being said we've
still got two more ports that we can
definitely use to charge other things
so this Mophie being 22,000 milliamps
because will give us 15 hours of laptop
life eight hours on DSLR cameras 21
hours on large tablets and 100 hours on
smartphones a hundred hours do you
believe it cuz I just you know I just
don't know well this looks absurd I
can't imagine this is something that
most normal people would carry around
but let me show you what I do normally
carry around and mind you I almost
always have a large purse for a backpack
so I'm always fully prepared with my
batteries a little baby brother or baby
sister too this one is this guy this was
one of what there USBC versions this was
meant to charge laptops but can you tell
the size comparison between the baby
this is more than double this little guy
what I liked about this one is it had a
USBC charger so this was basically made
to charge us PC laptops not just laptops
anything that was USB C powered like
most phones other than iPhones nowadays
but it's okay I'm not mad so we have
22,000 19,000 the one that I was using
before this was actually twenty thousand
this one is fairly old I think it's
maybe about a year old the only thing
that I didn't like is it was kind of big
but I did get a little bit more life out
of this and it also has three USB ports
whereas this one only has two it has one
USB a and one USB see there before this
one I was using this one and this Mophie
right here is still one of my favorites
even though I think this one is about
15,000 milliamps I love the slim form
factor this thing has went all around
the world with me and what's great is I
could always flip it right into the
front of the seat pocket it fits in
almost any laptop bag any of my purses
and for whatever reason I love this one
too because I felt like it always
charged my devices a little bit faster
even though these ports are basically
all the same ratings as all the others
still just felt like it was charging
very very quick also super reliable
sometimes I feel like when I use some of
the newer movies they don't always seem
as reliable as far as like the battery
goes thistles
it's three bars but then sometimes it'll
just drop down very quickly but this one
has never failed me ever except for like
that sound that's definitely not
something that you should ever hear
I don't you think they sell this one
anymore it was still my favorite anyway
these are my current Mophie selections
and yeah this is excessive I don't think
this is something that I will carry
around on a daily basis but if I am at
something like CES or if I am going out
to fly my drone I can charge one of my
smaller drone batteries off of this
thing some of the newer drones you can
charge just using usb so this is great
too because I will have so much extra
power I am extremely excited to try this
out I'm sure I will do a follow-up on
this maybe not a specific entirely
dedicated video but I'm sure I will
mention it at some point in a vlog or
something or on Twitter I don't know I
just don't think I can see myself well I
could see myself making an entire other
video about updating you on this thing
about a link in the description where
you can check out this one and some
previous movies there are some other
movies that I do use that are a little
bit smaller they have a lot of them let
me see if I can find one for you oh wow
I hit my foot I'm supposed to be having
this video until I went into my Mophie
drawer now full disclosure I have been a
movie partner for a while so they have
sent me some movies in the past this
pile they've never sent me
usually they send kind of a special
edition one like this supreme one which
I know a lot of you guys were into they
also sent me some of these that I just
seen ones which I basically only gave
out to some of my friends when my book
was released but these ones are so much
smaller which is probably better for
most normal users like you don't need
this but I feel like I'm always charging
something or somebody's always asking me
for chargers while I bring this out as I
just need to show you this too because
these ones are great because you don't
have to have another cable these have
the cable built-in directly so this has
a lightning adapter and it'll change to
a micro USB so depending on which type
of phone you have or what device you're
trying to charge this is already
built-in which is very very nice and
this one it looks like it is 12,000
milliamps so 12,000 that's actually
quite a lot that's a lot more than I
thought it was in here because if this
is 15 and this is 12 and you're 15 we
this one I actually broke although it
says it's still working but I'm not sure
if I believe it this has wireless
charging built into it that works
voila okay well that's actually working
so now I'm shocked because for a while
this plug wasn't working because I
dropped it and some things happen I'm
actually quite excited that this works
now how many milliamps are you this is
ten thousand I'm Chuck
I just reorganized all of my davits this
is not a movi this one is my Belkin but
I did an unboxing of this before this
has a Bolton Apple watch charger so you
just place your little Apple watch right
there
and this also charges this one is only
6700 so you're not gonna get much of a
charge but I do like this because it
does have the Apple watch charger
built-in so as for my suggestions on
chargers this is probably one my
favorites as far as Portability and
packing a lot of power
this one is incredible because it does
wireless charging it so glad it's
working good I love portable power so
much like I'm so prepared for the
apocalypse
well I'm not actually that hurt this
might only get me through like a week
plus some of these aren't charged I
forgot to do some charging it's Friday
night and baby I am at home hanging out
with my Mophie chargers look what is
happening sometimes when I just like
stop and think like what did I do in my
life to get me to the point where I'm
making videos about my loved a portable
power
some people have hobbies like running
knitting this is mine
[Music]
I think you guys so much for watching
let me know in the comments below what
charges do you guys use is this a little
bit excessive should I get a new hobby
should I go outside I think I'm probably
maybe we should go outside not right now
cuz it's late and it's dark out so I'm
gonna go out at this video bye
[Music]
you